c'est un mec un microbide vraiment il
gagne à l'Euromillions et il s'aperçoit
que New York un hôpital avec un très
grand chirurgien ils font des greffes de
bits il arrive là-bas au pied d'une tour
immense de portes soufre devant lui
et il rentre dans une première pièce et
le grand type en smoking arrive avec
trois valises première valise va dire ça
c'est le modèle standard mais c'est
quand même du 24 cm troisième valise
chacun
[Musique]
merci monsieur
il y en a qu'une toi 42 cm il a les
livrer avec des rondelles en peau de
chameau si jamais mais là le mec il
réfléchit il a le pognon là dans la
valise et lui dit
sinon
en blanc vous n'avez rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]